si h a es un ácido genérico y done a
este protón entonces los electrones de
este enlace se quedan en nada aunque por
aquí podemos dibujarlos y están formando
a menos entonces a menos es la base
conjugada del ácido h
ahora sí a menos es una base muy estable
entonces es más probable que este ha
sido donde este protón así es que si
quieres determinar la acidez de un
compuesto puedes fijarte en la
estabilidad de la base conjugada entre
más estables sea una base conjugada más
probable es que el ácido donde su proto
entonces entre más estable sea la base
conjugada más fuerte es el ácido
entonces usemos ese concepto y
apliquemos lo a los cuatro compuestos
que tenemos por aquí vamos a empezar con
el metano y el valor de pk
de este protón del metano es
aproximadamente de 48 para el amoniaco
el valor de pk de cualquiera de estos
protones es aproximadamente 36 para el
agua el pk de este protón es
aproximadamente 16 y en el hf este
protón de aquí tiene aproximadamente un
valor de pk
de 3 y sabemos que entre más chico sea
el valor de pk
más fuerte es el ácido y conforme nos
vamos hacia la derecha podemos observar
que los valores pk están decreciendo que
hay de crecemos de 48 a 36 a 16 ya 3
entonces conforme nos vamos hacia la
derecha aumenta la fuerza de estos
ácidos
así es que hf es el ácido más fuerte de
estos
el ácido más
fuerte y si hf es el ácido más fuerte de
estos cuatro entonces hf debe de tener
la base con jugada más estable ahora
vamos a pensar en las bases con jugadas
de estos cuatro compuestos y para eso
tenemos que ir hacia abajo si el metano
dona este producto entonces los
electrones de este enlace se quedan en
el carbono y el carbono obtiene una
carga formal negativa -1 y por acá si
nos llevamos este protón entonces estos
electrones se quedan en el nitrógeno y
el nitrógeno ahora tiene una carga
formal negativa -1 para el agua si nos
llevamos este hidrógeno los electrones
de este enlace se quedan en el oxígeno
formando un año ni hidróxido y
finalmente si nos llevamos este
hidrógeno este protón estos electrones
del enlace se quedan con el flúor
electrones se quedan con el flúor
formando el anillo floruro ya sabemos
que h efe es el ácido más fuerte de
estos cuatro ácidos y entonces debe de
tener la base con jugada más estable
entonces el anillo en fluoruro debe de
ser la base con jugada más estable y
conforme nos vamos moviendo hacia la
derecha va aumentando el nivel de
estabilidad de las bases con jugadas que
hay va aumentando la estabilidad y la
verdad es que si podemos explicar esta
tendencia lo único que tenemos que hacer
es fijarnos en el átomo que tiene la
carga negativa ok
este compuesto fue nuestra base con
jugada menos estable y su carga negativa
está en el átomo de carbono luego
tenemos que la carga negativa la tiene
el nitrógeno y esta base conjugada es un
poquito más estable que la anterior y
por acá la carga negativa la tiene el
oxígeno
y es un poquito más estable y finalmente
la carga negativa la tiene el flúor que
es la base con jugada más estable de
todas y bueno si lo observamos con mucho
cuidado nos podemos dar cuenta que esta
es la misma tendencia que la tendencia
de la electro negatividad nuclear y el
carbono es el menos electro negativo de
estos cuatro átomos luego tenemos el
nitrógeno que es un poquito más electro
negativo que el carbono luego el oxígeno
un poquito más y finalmente el flúor que
es el más electro negativo de los cuatro
no creéis sabemos que conforme nos
movemos hacia la derecha en la tabla
periódica aumenta la electro negatividad
así es que el flúor es el átomo más
electro negativo de los cuatro y el
elemento más electro negativo atrae más
a los electrones le encanta tener
electrones a su alrededor por lo tanto
tiene todo el sentido del mundo que el
flúor sea
mejor estabilizando una carga negativa y
eso es lo que hace que esté sea la base
con jugada más estable y si esta es la
base con jugada más estable
eso significa que h efe es el ácido más
fuerte entonces cuando estés pensando en
que tan fuerte es un ácido piensa en qué
tan estable es su base con jugada y en
qué factores ayudan a que una base sea
más estable y recuerda que la electro
negatividad es uno de esos factores que
hacen que una base sea más estable